[Musique]
c'est avec vous Antoine fenaud Antoine
bonsoir je voudrais revenir ce soir sur
ces allégations russes d'utilisation
d'une bombe sale par les Ukrainiens oui
absolument souvenez-vous on en avait
régulièrement parlé sur notre antenne
depuis le 23 octobre dernier il me
semble que c'est de souvenirs que
c'était dimanche avec cette affirmation
russe donc les Ukrainiens se
prépareraient à utiliser une bombe sale
c'est quoi c'est une bombe avec un
explosif conventionnel entouré de
matériel radioactif dans le but et bien
de faire un maximum de dégâts et bien le
ministère russe de la Défense sur
Twitter et bien à relayer de nouveaux
ces allégations vous les apercevez ici
il l'a accompagné de ce qu'on peut
qualifier de diapositives avec des
schémas se disant pour montrer selon eux
une illustration des capacités
ukrainiennes à produire ces fameuses
bombes salles vous voyez ici un exemple
de ce tweet il date lui aussi du 24
octobre et il émane directement du
ministère de la Défense russe une
affirmation qui a également un circulé
sur télégram toujours sur la chaîne
télégram du ministère de la Défense
russe vous voyez en dessous ces fameux
diable ces fameuses diapositives il y en
a trois au total on va y revenir un
petit peu plus tard à noter également
donc c'est même affirmations ont été
reprises assez sans surprise il faut
bien le dire par les comptes prorus
notamment par ce compte francophone qui
est basé en Afrique donc et vous avez
retrouvé Antoine la source de ces images
oui absolument et donc ces fameuses
diapositives que je vous évoquais voilà
je vais vous les mettre ici il y en a
trois au total et on va on va les
analyser une par une pour vous montrer
en quoi chaque image est pertinente ou
non on va donc commencer par la première
que vous voyez donc juste ici et cette
première en réalité elles ne montrent
pas du matériel russe notamment c'est
cette image tout à droite qui va nous
intéresser vous la voyez juste ici on
voit soi-disant selon cette affirmation
du de du ministère de la Défense russe
des instituts de recherche
Ukrainiens en physique nucléaire le
problème c'est qu'avec une simple
recherche d'image à verser on se rend
compte et bien et bien que cette
cette installation n'est pas du tout en
Ukraine mais qu'elle est en Russie et on
la retrouvée notamment sur cet article
de l'agence de de presse russe tasse il
s'agit de la il s'agit d'un réacteur à
neutron basé à Saint-Pétersbourg à
l'article lui vous le voyez date du 8
février
2021 voilà donc pour cette première
diapositive donc on va passer sur la
deuxième celle-ci qui elle est bien
selon le toujours le ministère de la
Défense russe mais en avant les
capacités
ukrainiennes à créer donc cette fameuse
bombe ça les liens et là encore il y a
beaucoup d'éléments qui clochent
notamment ces deux photos que vous voyez
en bas à gauche je vais vous les
agrandir un petit peu pour qu'on les on
les voit un petit peu mieux à l'écran
notamment vous voyez celle-ci elle est
censée montrer un réacteur de recherche
scientifique et là encore ben c'est raté
il ne s'agit absolument pas d'une
structure ukrainienne mais là encore
d'une structure russe voici la photo
originale elle est elle est elle est
cette fois-ci
issue du
elle est issue d'une centrale qui est
basée à bélugarce très précisément
l'article lui il a été publié par un
autre site d'agent officiel enfin un
autre site de presse russe newcea et il
date du 26 20 mars pardon 2020 donc rien
à voir en avec l'Ukraine et enfin la
photo que je vous montrais juste ici en
bas à droite je vais vous l'agrandir
légèrement pour qu'on puisse mieux la
voir c'est un scientifique visiblement
qui est en train de préparer du
combustible en tout cas ce qui ressemble
à des pièces de combustible pour une
centrale nucléaire et bien là encore
rien à voir cette photo elle la voici
c'est une photo originale donc la voici
elle est issue du site qui s'appelle
wonderful ingénering et elle date de
2016 elle a été prise là dans le corps
dans une unité de traitement chimique
russe cette fois-ci à Novo cybirk et
enfin pour cette dernière image que vous
voyez juste ici à droite vous voyez ces
petits sacs remplis soi-disant de
matériel radioactif envoie les logos ici
et bien là encore il ne s'agit pas d'une
d'une
de matériel
ukrainien il s'agit en réalité d'une
photo qui vient de Slovénie et le
gouvernement sloven vous le voyez a
démenti cette information sur son compte
Twitter en disant qu'il ne s'agissait
pas de matériel ukrainien mais qu'il
s'agissait en réalité de détecteur de
fumée qui s'agit qui viennent
effectivement d'une d'une d'un site
traitant de matériel nucléaires donc
clair et ce n'est pas la première fois
que cette technique est utilisée
absolument et pour se rendre compte il
suffit de regarder cette dernière cette
dernière diapositive avec notamment ses
images notamment à gauche où vous voyez
la fameuse provocation chimique on va le
faire assez assez rapidement en réalité
cette image que vous voyez juste à
gauche elle avait déjà été utilisée dans
le cadre de la guerre en Syrie
souvenez-vous et c'était en fait il
extrait d'un reportage sur ces fameux
casques blancs vous savez ces
volontaires syriens qui venaient en aide
aux populations civile victime des
bombardements en fait il s'agit d'un
extrait de film et les Russes avaient
détourné à l'époque pour accuser ces
fameux casques blancs de mettre en scène
des crimes de guerre vous voyez donc
encore une info que je recycle et pour
être tout complet sachez enfin et bien
que l'Ukraine les États-Unis la France
le Royaume-Uni ont fait un communiqué
commun pour dire et bien qu'il n'y avait
que ces allocations de bombe salles
étaient fausses ils voyaient ici comme
il le voyait il le présentait donc c'est
mises à faire étrangères comme une
allégation à un prétexte d'escalade donc
merci beaucoup Antoine fenaud on peut
retrouver votre chronique sur notre site
internet
www.france24.com nous on se retrouve
dans